le fanatisme en france n'existe que pour
dynamiser l il est beau et c'est nul
ma passion c'est johnny hallyday un dieu
pour des générations de femmes des
hommes et des femmes de tout âge fasciné
par le rockeur en 1968
josette faisait partie de ses groupies
sa chemise c'est johnny qui m'a donné à
l'olympia 67
je monte sur scène les chercher ou bien
les acheter de williana que j'ai eu
quand il a acheté mes enfants d'avoir
une quand il la jette c'est pas très
facile et être fan de johnny ça n'a pas
de prix
exemple ici en 1985 pour s'offrir le
disque d'or de son idole cet homme
n'avait pas hésité à contracter un
emprunt
quand on a une passion solo vous y en a
qui ont peut-être acheter une voiture
neuve
moi j'ai mis mon argent l'acteur robin
n'en sais rien quand la voiture sera
peut-être hui est foutu j'espère que
dans cinq ans le disque n'y sera pas une
folie qui ce jour-là dépassé même le
principal intéressé pour ça
seulement quand j'ai été fan de james
bulger était fan de l'espace mais je ne
sais pas si j'aurais su j'aurais acheté
un disque d'or quelques heures je ne
sais pas c'est mon fanatisme arrêter
sinon plus que du fanatisme voici ici de
la dévotion
ce prêtre avait lui aussi été touché par
la grâce d'allah l'idée en 1985 il
dévoilait sa collection
c'est ma carte de membre du club et
sourire et voyelles je suis quand même à
des premiers parce que je vois le numéro
584 et je suis même encore en soutane
autre époque autres fans voici jeanine
en 1993 son coup de foudre pour johnny
elle l'affiché au grand jour sur les
murs de son café dit qu'il apparaît que
tu as le compte à rebours qui fait tu
sais 19,8 au qui arrive
je tremble de partout où j'ai à mon
vieux cahier mon coeur il est fort très
fort un amour inconditionnel que
certains graves mm dans la peau le
joueur partirait jouer j'aurai dans le
projet de lui avec moi que la johnny
magna continuera dans les années 2000 et
même après la mort du chanteur
on met il est mortel a forcément il va
il va passer les siècles et les siècles
on s'en souviendra encore longtemps et
en plus des fans certaines villes
françaises rendent aussi hommage à
johnny après toulouse la mairie de paris
envisage à son tour une esplanade au nom
du chanteur que je fais une erreur
[Musique]